governments made a formal offer to the
NHS staff Council that I've just come
out of a meeting with them I'm very
pleased that they've agreed to recommend
to their members it will be for a five
percent pay rise next year
2023-24 but also an additional lump sum
in terms of this year which is
additional to the award through the pay
review body which was on average 4.75
percent and then what that will mean for
example for a newly qualified nurse is
over 1 800 this year on top of that prb
award and a pay rise of over 1 300
pounds next year and obviously that
increases for more senior nurses in
higher grades now of course some of that
money for this year is a one-off payment
which means it doesn't go long term into
the salaries of those people you've said
frequently that you wouldn't look at
this year's pay why didn't you do this
earlier well we have listened to the
concerns of the train units we've had
meaningful discussions with them we're
both sides of engaged constructively
obviously the starting position from the
number of the unions was much higher and
so both sides have worked together to
reach a settlement which is both
affordable to The Wider taxpayer who
imbalances the very real pressures we
recognize that NHS workers have been on
so this balance was required on both
sides that is what the talks explored
and that's why I very much welcome that
we've reached a settlement with the NHS
staff Council that balances our
commitment in government to get
inflation down to look at the cost and
what was affordable to The Wider economy
to taxpayers but that also recognize the
very real pressures that NHS staff faced
through the pandemic and particularly
through the recent winter so an
important question how much is it going
to cost and how will it be funded uh
well we've been clear that it will not
come at the expense of uh impact on
patients obviously how these things are
funded or a matter for the chancellor
and we discuss that within government uh
but we've been offered any new money he
didn't in the budget very clear in terms
of the conditions of the discussions we
had with the trade unions that this will
not come from patient-facing aspects of
course we will look at areas of under
spend as an administrative saving and
discuss these things with the treasury
in the usual way but the commitment is
one that the trade unions have
recognized is Meaningful it reflects
very constructive engagement with them
it means there will be a lump sum
additional four NHS staff this year
recognizing the pressures and a five
percent settlement for next year
important though there are Hospital
trusts who are very concerned that even
if some of this has to come out of
existing budgets is going to mean more
pain for patients well we're being clear
that as part of the discussions we had
this would not come from areas of the
budget that impact on patients so those
was part of the terms of the discussions
that we had that was the nature of the
negotiation now that was part of the
Monday I received from the Prime
Minister and from the chancellor there
are many people though who will look at
this and say this dispute has been going
on for months there was talk of a
one-off payment several weeks ago months
ago in fact were you blocked from doing
that and pursuing that by the treasury
well we take decisions across government
these things are entered into
collectively of course part of my job as
the Health and Social care secretary is
to advocate for the NHS within
government in exactly the same way that
the education secretary will do so for
teachers or the transport secretary for
train drivers my job is to make the case
for the NHS within government of course
that is something that I have been doing
over recent months but we make these
decisions collectively I'm very pleased
we've reached a settlement which the NHS
staff Council feel able to recommend to
their members it balances our commitment
to get inflation down to guard the
interests of the taxpayer but does so in
a balanced way that also reflects the
the very real pressures that the NHS has
been under over recent years you've been
forced to the negotiating table haven't
you by the strike action and for those
people who've had operations and
treatment canceled postponed potentially
for months or years they're going to say
you should have done something sooner
well there's been significant movement
in terms of what the trade unions were
originally asking for for example one of
the trade unions originally was
suggesting a 19 settlement so there's
been movement on all sides we moved some
time ago though didn't they well not to
the position that we're on today so
there's been further constructive
engagement we've had intensive talks
over many days there's been movement on
both sides and that reflects the
balanced nature of the settlement we've
reached looking after the interests of
taxpayers getting inflation down but
recognizing the real pressures that the
NHS has faced and just finally I know
you'll be pleased of course that you
seem to have reached an agreement here
but Junior doctors it doesn't include
Junior doctors does it no my door is
open I look forward to having
discussions with them clearly we entered
the talks with the agenda for change
trade unions on the basis of them
suspending their strikes respecting the
engagement principles I welcome the the
leadership that the trade unions have
shown in those discussions we've built a
discussions that have respected the
confidentiality uh throughout both sides
have been willing to work in a very
constructive way and I hope the junior
adopters will take note of that and
reflect that in their approach over the
coming weeks and your message to them is
they need to suspend strike action is
that right yes that's the principles
which the other trade unions accepted
the RCN uh unite Unison the GMB all
respected that we've offered the same
terms to the junior doctors that were
accepted by those other trade unions and
that's what I hope the junior doctors
will respond to but a request from them
for a pay rise of 35 is not affordable
that's why we need to see from them the
same sort of leadership that we've seen
from the trade unions in the agenda for
change contract